it is 1966
in his studio famed hollywood couturier
jean-louis is designing a wardrobe
modernist tomorrow waistline anywhere
from hip to bust skirt length short
short short for what picture for this
one
you're kidding this is back in the 20s
correction the exciting 20s
that's when a state old world began to
go mud observe please
get the idea
but presto a turn of a door and suddenly
we have a thoroughly modern milly
hey that's julie andrews
down buster
the revolution in dress that started in
the emancipated 20s is still going on
let's study it a bit through millie and
her friends hold it millie
ladies it's all yours take it away
simple yet jaunty in spirit this
everyday outfit is worn by julie andrews
consists of a light gray jumper of thin
wool with black pocketed hip bands
pleated skirt white silk crate blouse no
synthetic fabrics in those days you know
and green accessories
being newly emancipated but a working
secretary on a slim budget
milly bright girl that she is simply
alters accents and colors and voila
she has several changes
but millie always dresses with flair
this white silk crepe has black and
white checkered board trim at the hip
line
checkerboard bordered sleeves and hat
paneled strips over a vermillion skirt
and a vermillion carnation add a dash of
color
a charming little number for street and
restaurant wear
silver gray crepe with white polka dots
dickie and cuffs of white organdy coral
hat and coral trim
the skirt is three-tiered and circular
dash in a dinner dress
you'll find it in the harlequin cut of
the gunmetal trim in skirt and cuffs
over a dress of corn flower yellow crepe
georgette belted at the hips
millie's go to a wedding dress is misty
gray souffle with handkerchief hem skirt
split sleeves worn with matching tool
hat trimmed with pink roses
just great
what do you wear to vamp your boss
millie has the answer
let your eyes flash lightning and your
costume too
the dress is a black and white satin
crepe the hat is black and white felt
does it work
let's see
do you have a bow
what a moment
i would just love to get a friend's
opinion of the ruloff valentino
i mean in the sikh he takes agnes heirs
by brute force
and she enjoys it
she enjoys it a lot hmm
what is your opinion of
brute force mr green
milly's friend miss dorothy is very rich
very conservative very elegant and
dresses accordingly
hey that's mary tyler moore from the
dick van dyke show
for a party then or now what could be
happier ice blue satin veiled with white
neck blue rose petals scattered on a
skirt of silk neck the matching shoes
have diamond buckles
also in the party mood a yellow chiffon
hand embroidered sheep with a low belted
panel sash
glamour for the boudoir or the house
party pajamas of pear blue satin with
harem trousers banded at the ankles and
a touch of luxury in the paneled
chantilly lace sleeves
a dress for many occasions this to wear
as a wedding guest
pink ship on and lace many tiered and
pleated skirt and pink rose petal
picture hat make this a picture indeed
what ever happened to basic black
here it is in black lace over nude
sunburst pleated skirt black satin sash
tied with a yellow rose and shoes with
cut steel buckles
but let's not leave miss dorothy without
seeing her in her wedding gown jean
louise dream creation
the dress is of allenson lace with two
skirt lace bodice and veil
the tool veil banded with lace is
delicately trimmed with orange blossoms
a dream indeed
but it's that dolly carol channing
playing the richest and wildest widow
since auntie mame who gets to wear
jean-louise most glamorous way out
costumes and jewels
topped by a hat trimmed with bleached
white vulture feathers carol's outfit
consists of a white speckled silk dress
with side panel and bolero effect in
back
for a simple accent a rather stupendous
emerald necklace and bracelet
but everything about muzzy is stupendous
even her walking outfit
knickerbockers of heavy silk silk tie
and shirt diamond stick pin and
cufflinks even the hand knit pullover
has a diamond pattern
muzzy's hostess t gown is white silk
crepe the bell sleeves are trimmed in
curled ostrich the rope belt is weighted
with diamond spheres
accessories
a diamond choker
for airplaning one needs something
special and muzzy's flying costume
certainly is
white silk
patch pockets urban collar and cuffs
the trousers are banded and buckled
under the jacket a cashmere sweater
diamond choker and buckles of course
in an outfit like this any girl could
fly
a house party and an elegant mansion
requires something special in night
attire
with romance in mind julie wears white
satin crate pajamas under a sleeveless
white chiffon negligee with ruffle trim
and turquoise belt and bow
no wonder the house party becomes a
pajama party
mozzie's pajamas are of crepe georgette
pleated and tiered sleeves and pants
note the long necklace
but the piazza resistance is this
diamond dress
designed for fluid movement the dress is
nevertheless fully encrusted with
jeweled bugle beads and diamonds
the panels are designed to swing and
sway over a nude skirt
a diamond dog collar and bracelets add
sparkle to the overall effect
but the most sparkle the greatest
chihuahua davi radiate from carol
herself
yes zest and high spirits characterize
the costumes in ross hunter's thoroughly
modern millie as befits a zestful and
spirited time
the beginning of the mod age
you